[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Präsident die mortart von
Hanau erschüttert und wühlt auf was auch
erschüttert ist die reflexhafte Hetze
mit der hier
Opfer zur parteipolitischen Münze
geschlagen werden sie spannen ermorde
Menschen die Motivation des Täters
entwickelt hat aber doch
unzurechnungsfähig das bejaht er nicht
ihre Diffamierung
das ist der wahre Sachstand
was war seine Gedankenwelt hier in
diesem Manifest telepathischen Kontrolle
ritueller Missbrauch von Kindern in
unterirdischen Basen er habe mit
Gedanken den nein eleven-terror bewirkt
er war verrückt und der AFD soll es in
die Schuhe geschoben werden um das
nächste fehlerteil des Verfassungsschutz
für den Wähler plausibler zu machen nein
nicht aus Worten aus Wahnvorstellungen
wurden da taten
der Täter
beschreibt vernichtungsphantasien die
ganze Menschheit betreffen drei Zitate
alle eliminieren auch wenden wir von
mehreren Milliarden sprechen wenn ein
Knopf zur Verfügung steht würde ich
diesen sofort drücken zudem müssen wir
eine Zeitschleife fliegen und den
Planeten zerstören
offensichtlich keine politische Agenda
die psychotische Verfasstheit lässt sich
nicht vom konkreten tatverhalten
abtragen um darunter ein warnfreies rein
politisches Motiv zu entdecken was hat
Ihnen zu seiner Wahnsinns Tat getrieben
er sagt nach einem miterlegten
Banküberfall wurden ihm zu 90%
ausländische Verdächtigen Profile
vorgelegt das wird Schlüsselerlebnis
deshalb ganzer Völker auslöschen zu
wollen er nennt über 20 Länder diese
krankhafte Übersteigerung das ist gerade
das wahnhafte der geistlich gesunde
Mensch reagiert auf Missstände indem er
die AFD wählt
das bewaffnete irre im Land rumlaufen
ist Staatsversagen selbst nach einer
wahnhaften Anzeige des Täters wurde
nicht ermittelt wegen möglicher
Gefährdung Waffenbesitz wir fordern
Prävention statt Polemik keine Waffen in
den Händen von verrückten
Schluss auch mit ihrer Verrohung der
Sprache die AFD ist für einen Herrn März
Gesindel für Laschet bis aufs Messer zu
bekämpfen für ein wanderwitz Gift ja
Abschaum diese Sprache ist eine Schande
für dieses Land und für ihre
Kanzlerkandidaten die Diffamierung
Faschist Nazi ist zum alltäglichen
Kleingeld ihrer Verleumdung geworden das
ist Willkommenskultur für Rufmord sie
wollen durch Verfilmung der Opposition
eine verfehlte Regierungspolitik gegen
Kritik immunisieren wir sagen die
Wahrheit ist der Gesellschaft zumutbar
Herr Kollege kurio gestanden sie eine
Zwischenfrage der nicht Hass bewegt
viele Bürger sondern gerechte Empörung
über Illegalität und falsche Politik mit
der sie das Land Spalten heute hier mit
haltlosen Schuldzuweisungen der
eigentliche Brandstifter beschuldigt den
Feuermelder
die AFD zeigt den Bürgern das ist einen
gewaltfreien parlamentarischen Weg gibt
zur Beseitigung der Missstände deshalb
ist die Existenz der AFD die beste
Versicherung dieses Landes gegen
Extremismus
[Applaus]